thank you so much for all the support in
yesterday's video because you know I
didn't upload a video for almost a week
so I was a bit nervous thinking will
these guys forget about me we will still
remember but I see that you guys still
remember and the market maker does too
because this was yesterday's uh Bitcoin
projection and we were talking about the
idea that it looked like the market
maker was building his lungs over here
okay with these weeks
but we're talking about this week he
gets filled with 50 with this one okay
but once then we get filled you want to
see an immediate reaction to the upside
they want to see a bounce when you don't
see a bounce and you see some sideways
move then that's telling you they're
gonna take another attempt to continue
filling this week even more and that's
the drop they fill their weak even more
and then that's when they bounce okay
that's the reaction so that was what
we're talking about in yesterday's video
and how we were favoring prices to the
upside in the next 48 hours you only
take a couple of hours to just pump
price up so we took advantage of this
move because uh I was telling you that I
think that the range loose because if
you notice these are this was a previous
range so this white line over here does
the range lose that was a good place to
long but if you could catch also this
moparity over here that would also be a
good place to add to the position okay
that was my case and I know that some of
you did that did the same so that's the
pump and now if you notice is we still
have a real problem and that's the
4r50ma because we tested our resistance
and then we saw a r reaction from there
okay
that we've just reached a major
resistance we get the 4 hour 50 minutes
so from here let's see what it does okay
because today is Thursday we will have
Thursday and Friday so two days before
the weekend the weekend we are probably
gonna see some sideways move and nothing
really happening so so let's discuss
what we could potentially see today and
tomorrow okay so this pump
is it finished
that's the first question okay
well it's difficult to answer okay in my
opinion I don't think it's finished
okay I don't think it's finished it's
true that we have here a big resistance
the 450 May uh it might take some time
to get above it uh I don't know if it's
gonna be today tomorrow or maybe on
Monday okay but I do think that there is
a chance that we still Target the
mid-range okay and that's 27 000.
because if you notice when you're in a
Range okay you usually go all the time
to the mid-range check this out here for
example okay you go down then you go to
the mid-range okay to go down you go to
the mid range you go down you go to the
mid range all the time it continuously
happened the same okay in this range
above here it happens the same okay you
go down mid-range down mid-range down
mid-range all the time okay you can see
all the time
so that's why I'm thinking
that we still probably are gonna go to
the metering to some point okay um
hopefully that can happen quite soon now
the four hour time frame is today is not
looking great because you got yourselves
that big resistance there okay uh 26 777
at the moment but if you check the one
hour time frame that's not looking that
bad is it okay because
um you had let me remove this a second
you had this resistance here that was
the 150ma for quite some time and I will
tell you when you see price testing a
level as resistance but you don't see a
sell-off that is telling you that there
is a motive to price price up okay
because the retail traded is when I see
this and it's gonna continue placing
shorts all the time for in this case in
the 1 hour 53 because then I want to try
to take advantage of these moves so in
one of these attempts the market
necklace just gonna Spike price up and
stop those Traders
and Reverse by surprise okay so what do
I think we might see here well I think
that we should test the one or 50ma to
be honest okay so don't be surprised if
in today's New York session you see a
drop
to this level okay then what you want is
this level to hold okay because if you
lose this level
and then you test it as resistance then
yeah the the pump will be over at least
for this week okay and maybe you can
even go again to the rangeless bow
as long as today which I think is going
to happen okay I think that today is
very likely that we come to the one or
50 I mean the New York session and then
from here
this is where you want to pay attention
to okay because if you see another
reaction from here then we might Target
then the mid-range
all right
so uh that's what I'm looking for today
uh I'm just gonna wait now to see if we
can get that retest of the 1r50 me and
see the reaction in Bitcoin okay uh
pretty simple now if we go into the
daily time frame
as I told you yesterday okay it's not
looking great because if you notice here
if you lose this level okay so if you
lose this level over here
what are you going to go well you are
eventually gonna go
this is the next potential support
okay
and that's uh 20K
so uh do I think that we're gonna go to
20K straight away
I don't and I'm gonna go down to high
blood Capital I'm gonna explain you why
I think that it's more likely that we
hold Above This range for quite some
time okay before coming back down I do
think that it's likely that in the next
uh three six months
Bitcoin goes and fills this week over
here
okay I mean this week in the weekly time
frame
and that's at twenty thousand seven
hundred so I think that will eventually
get there
if I'm honest with you but in the short
term I'm expecting more ranging over
here okay more consolidation over here
and we're gonna go now to hybrid capital
and I'm going to explain to you why
didn't have a capital three months time
frame and we've been talking about this
liquidation zone for quite a while okay
24 200. that's up uh an important
liquidation so so if you notice here
there was a week and we didn't hit this
zone for only a couple of hundred
dollars
okay and now price is consolidating
above there why I always tell you the
same you've heard this before
and probably you've just answered the
the question by yourself whoa usually
when you see price attacking a
liquidation Zone but not hitting it and
and missing it by a couple of hundred
dollars or you know quite a small
difference that is telling you that the
market Maker's idea is to consolidate
above it like it's doing right now okay
we may even see a pump because they want
to induce traders to open longs
if their induce traders to open lungs
for example with a jester-based pump and
if they continue pumping there is going
to be more Longs open because the retail
Trader is programmed to open long swim
prices going up and open shorts when
price is going down the retail Trader
only trades based on emotions
okay so what they're trying to do now in
my opinion is to use traders to open
lungs why because then with high
leverage Traders opening their lungs
there is going to be a lot of more of
liquidations stacked in this Zone
okay so the liquidity that you had here
is 66 million what 66 Bill 66 billion
dollars by the way when this is in
higher time frame take this number with
a pinch of salt because you only goes so
they don't know when Traders are closing
positions okay so let's take this number
as a reference
don't take it seriously okay so 66
billion dollars worth of
long liquidations okay now if you notice
when we have this week and this
consolidation those liquidations from 66
billions go higher to 68 billions okay
so you can see how the liquidity is
going up because it's so windy that when
price consolidates above a liquidation
Zone that liquidation Zone
is going to get bigger and bigger and
bigger and that's going to be perfect
for the market maker in the future if
they want to drop price to this Zone
because they're gonna hit more
liquidations than they could have done
previously
I don't know if you guys are following
me okay uh so yes I do think that price
is consolidating above this liquidation
Zone and and they missed by a couple of
hundred dollars on purpose okay so
they're consolidating here for quite a
while
we might see a pump even higher okay uh
and the ultimate goal of this is
basically to induce traders to open
loans so the liquidations and this Zone
can increase and when they bring price
back down that wanna hit more
liquidations that they could have done
previously okay so that's what I think
that's what I think that in the midterm
or long term whatever you want to say
we're gonna come to the sun we want to
hit these liquidations but in the short
term I'm expecting more consolidation
more sideways or even up another pump
okay so Traders can open logs now if we
go into the seven days time frame I hope
that was clear guys
if not you know you can ask me in the
comments uh if we're going up to the
seven days time frame
and we take this Zone you can see that
at 27 000.
there are now a lot of liquidations why
well the same reason price is
consolidating at highs
and is well it's coming down you know
went all the way to 26 800 now we're at
26 400 so the retail Trader C is price
you know coming down maybe they drove
here some kind of a bearish pennant or
something and they think okay price is
gonna go down so I'm gonna open shorts
that's when the liquidity at 27k is
increasing again if you notice here
since this moment price is dropping the
liquidity increases because the retail
Traders open shorts when price is going
down okay so in the short term is still
targeting 27 000 because now we have the
conference of the liquidation zones with
the mid-range that is the same level if
you remember okay so that's what we are
targeting at the moment okay
I think that today is very likely that
we see a drop to 26 250 or so that's the
150 I mean and then I would like to see
a retest of support so we can continue
climbing higher to 27k in the short term
hopefully we get to restart it this week
but I don't ever want to get there okay
let's see how price moves also tomorrow
on Friday Jerome Powell is going to be
speaking so that's when I move also the
markets okay we want to talk about that
tomorrow but that's what I'm thinking
for this for term
and then in the midterm I just think
we're gonna continue going lower all
right so that's pretty much everything
guys why I assured update
um I'm gonna continue charting altcoins
because uh I do think that the big gains
in the next bull market are going to be
in the altcoins uh so I'm gonna go and
and charge small coins and I'm planning
to upload some article content this week
okay so thank you so much guys for
watching
and I'll see you soon